our minds our egos our preferences are
the sum of our learned experiences okay
and every single person has had
different experiences no one has ever
had the same experience as you not neat
leave with that no one has ever had it
and no one ever will you're the most
unique thing in the universe and so is
everybody else but since we're the sum
of our learned experiences or at least
our psyche is we're not the
Consciousness is not we are watching the
sum of a learned experiences The
Observer watches right so you're
absolutely right how can they be wrong
you think you're right you think you're
right she said don't dare do that I
can't believe you did that that was so
wrong right because based on your
experiences that's out of the question
on somebody else's experience they don't
know what you're talking about that's
why this whole politics stuff is so
stupid all right if they don't
understand they're just expressing the
sum and learned experiences and if you
had a different experience one different
experience you would have a different
opinion